in one of our favorite documentaries my
big break my Tony Sierra someone was
interviewed and says that you know most
people in LA get their big break they
either aren't ready for it or they don't
realize it when it happens can you look
back on a time when something was
presented to you and it seemed pretty
miniscule at the time and it was
actually life-changing that's a really
good question i don't know i think i'd
like to imagine that still may be ahead
of me you know in a lot of ways i can
not to say that of course i'm like the
opportunities I've had it been like
incredible but I still feel like I've
been gladly and I if the rest of my
career goes like this I'd be happy like
working kind of under the radar for a
bit you know I've kind of always had to
try to find my own way get these films
made you know I've always it's always
come together in some really sort of
strange untraditional way after like
three years or people telling me no like
both my movies have been that path and
so I feel like I've had to have it to
find it and build it for myself which
I've been happy to but I also but I
don't I haven't had like an accidental
thing yet you know I haven't had that
sort of like where I made something I
didn't think people are gonna see a ton
of people saw it you know as it hasn't
really been that yeah yeah but maybe it
hasn't i just don't realize it you know
i mean i think i think my first full
maybe as an indication of that like it
didn't it didn't get into Sundance it
didn't get into South by Southwest I
didn't get him to Tribeca didn't get
into I mean any of the major US
festivals and it felt like it was me to
totally disappear you know it kind of
felt like I made this thing i'm proud of
it i feel like it's good i feel like i
can stand by it but like no one is gonna
play it anywhere and and then we got you
know we got an opportunity to screen at
sinha vegas which doesn't exist anymore
but at the time was notable you know
enough to get the movie on the radar and
then and then the movie ended up getting
to Spirit Award nomination so it ended
up building to something you know so I
think as opposed to maybe something
being like a snapping point or like a
big break or like this big opportunity
it's just happening I think it's
happening very slowly and I'm working
really hard for it and I hope that like
I said if I if I keep on making movies
the same way I've been making them and I
keep them falling under the radar like
I'm fine with that to me I just want to
make movies I don't want to you know as
long as each to each film I feel like
lends itself the opportunity to get to
make the next one so that's that's what
I'm hoping for you know I don't know if
I'll ever be like a big big break like
that but I mean I mean getting into
Sundance is and I think in a weird way
maybe not getting to Sundance was like
it gave me a lot of perspective a lot
appreciation for when I did get to play
there I've had been my first time I
think I would have been thrilled but I
think it wouldn't maybe I wouldn't have
understand stood how hard it can really
be to get to play a movie there you know
and then just and a lot of people i know
just cuz you played one movie there
doesn't mean your next one's necessarily
gonna play their you know and the other
way around so there's not there's no
guarantee and i think i went in with
that appreciation and so it's okay hey
I'm really I felt really lucky you know
I really felt like I didn't feel like I
paid my dues of my first movie I got an
opportunity to now I just felt like I
got a chance to screen it there and this
particular movie appealed to them in a
specific way and um and that's great and
whether I ever hopefully get a chance to
play another movie there but if not I
did have that one experience which i
always want it so
you